it's just one of these things like if
you listen to any radio oh saying in the
mid-2000s you heard Nelly damn near
every hour yeah sounds like a soap
commercial yeah I look talk about an
artist that you keep forgetting is on
the lineup Nelly is on the Bonnaroo
lineup we totally forgot that Nelly was
part of this every time I look at the
poster I find a new artist that I forgot
about yeah how many of those are there
we keep looking down every time I look
they're gonna be there yeah Natalie is
gonna be there do you have fun that
shows gonna be he has ride with me
the dilemma country grammar that the hit
parade of Nellie's is gonna be on and on
and on where do you predict it's gonna
be I have no idea that's the thing that
I don't know I want it to be late-night
I want it to be late-night because it's
it's got a sexy groove to it and I know
it is still you know have the energy
that that keeps me keeps me going but
honestly here's where I want it to be I
want it to be against I want to be on
this against some sort of super Jam on
that and a EDM artists on the what or
the which yeah that's where I wanted so
I don't miss anything
because I'll go to Nelly and I won't
care about the super gym or the EDM
artists I want it to be right there on
this somewhere at about 12:30 1:00
o'clock kind of gather yourself
[Applause]
Julie to the stories that define the
artists plane who are they what are they
what will you see the what which bands
this year that matter David Brad Steiner
and Barry quarter